So I'm going to briefly review some of
what I told you last time and then I'm
going to walk through,
as I mentioned,
I'm going to walk through the Disney Film
Pinocchio and which I presume most of
you have seen.
How many have you seen it?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's,
that's so as I think I mentioned,
that's something in and of itself,
right?
I mean,
the fact that you've all seen it means
that it's an production of cultural
significance and because
it's such a strange artifact,
that's one way of looking at it.
It might be worth trying to take
it apart to understand why it is,
for example,
that you even understand it.
And so I offered you the proposition
last week that we view the world
essentially through a narrative lens.
And I believe that we view the world
through a narrative lens because of the
fundamental problem that we have to solve
as living creatures is how we should
act in the world.
And that means how we should
act to maintain ourselves,
but also how we need to act
in relationship to other
people and in relationship
to the broader world.
In order to maintain
ourselves across time.
So that's a complicated problem,
right?
It's not just how you survive,
it's how you survive now and next week
and next month and next year and 50 years
from now and maybe your,
your,
uh,
your descendants as well if the culture
is going to stabilize and then not only
you across all those timeframes but
you and everyone else across all those
timeframes to viciously difficult problem.
And so I would say that we have
evolved mechanisms to solve that.
Um,
I think that's self evident in
some sense because for example,
one of the mechanisms that animals have
evolved to deal with the problem of
social being,
even if they're not
particularly social animals,
is the dominance hierarchy.
Right?
Or You could call it a
hierarchy of authority or power.
Because I think considering
human structures,
social structures as mirror power
structures is a terrible mistake.
It's a terrible oversimplification
because power is by no means the
only like force is what I mean.
Force is not a stable way of solving the
problem of how to live together across
time.
The question is what is the stable way
of solving how to live together across
time?
And that really is the question and it's
part of the question that I'm trying to
answer partly because
it's a perennial problem,
right?
We,
we faced the problem of how to organize
ourselves in small social units without
undue conflict.
And then we faced the larger problem
of how to organize ourselves into large
social units without undue conflict.
And that conflict can be
absolutely devastating and,
and,
and frequently is so.
So then I would also say that the
first way of solving this problem isn't
conscious.
You say not at all.
And you know,
you may know and you may
not know that there are,
there are different forms of memory,
right?
Really technically
different forms of memory.
So for example,
there's short term working memory,
which is the memory that you use to hold
things like telephone numbers in your
act of imagination.
It decays very rapidly.
It's only about four to seven bits,
which is why,
well,
it's white phone numbers or
were at least seven digits long.
You know,
you can kind of manage that as a loop.
That,
and then there's um,
episodic memory and that has two elements.
One is semantic and the
other is a episodic.
It's a help.
What's the name of that?
Someone said something?
Yes.
Well there's procedural
memory and then there's,
there's another,
the kind of memory that you use to
represent your experiences to yourself.
So let's say it's image Laden and the
other one is semantic and semantic is your
memory for facts.
And those are quite different.
So for example,
procedural memory,
that's how you ride a bike.
That's how you play the piano.
That's how you play jazz music.
If you're in a combo,
it's,
it's the memory.
It's,
it's,
it's a funny kind of memory cause
it's actually built right into you.
You know,
I mean so as so as the kind of memory
that used to represent your life,
but it's much more
malleable in some sense.
So what that means is
that in your procedures,
there is information that you don't
know about pattern information that you
don't know about.
Part of that is how to act.
You know,
like when you walk into
a social gathering,
you don't really think through
how you're going to act.
You,
you know how to act and if someone
asked you exactly what it is that you're
doing and why you could
formulate a story about it,
but the probability that that it's the
existence of that story that enabled you
to act that way as zero because you
have to react way faster than that.
And so,
you know,
you have social knowledge built into
your nervous system because you've
practiced being a social being
for a very long period of time.
And of course then that social being
has been shaped for forever really.
And it's the right way
of thinking about it.
You know,
we know that animals organize themselves
into hierarchies and we'll say of
dominance because it's more,
more true the farther back you go in time,
at least since the time
of the crustaceans.
You know,
when we split from our common
ancestor 300 million years ago.
And so,
and it's true for social
animals and non social animals.
So even animals that don't live together
in groups have to organize themselves
into a hierarchy in
the space they inhabit.
Songbirds are a good example.
And they have dominance
disputes all the time.
Partly that's,
you can hear them having their little
dominance disputes in the spring when
they're singing because basically what
they're singing is I'm pretty damn
healthy and I'm ready to go.
And if you're another bird like me,
you better steer clear this tree.
And,
and the,
the dominant song birds,
you know,
they don't live together crozer social,
but most songbirds aren't.
The dominant songbirds get the best
nest and the best nest is the one that
doesn't get rained on isn't,
it's not too windy and it's close
to food sources and you know,
and so then they have the healthiest
chicks and they attract the best mates.
And like it's really important where
you're positioned in the hierarchy,
even if you're not like
a flock or herd creature.
Now we're more like herd creatures.
So it's even more,
it's even,
it's even more relevant to us,
but there's just no escaping
a hierarchical arrangement
in social being that is
social being.
And,
and,
and it's evolutionarily
ancient beyond conception.
So 300 million years
ago there weren't trees,
you know,
I mean,
so the dominance hierarchy
is older than trees.
So that's really something to think about.
And then you know,
when you're thinking about the reality
that shaped us say from an evolutionary
perspective,
but also from a cultural perspective,
what you have to understand is that the
things that have shaped us most are the
things that have been around the longest.
And so you could say those are the most
real things and you can't even see some
of them.
Like it's not like you can come in here.
Well it's not exactly true.
You can't come in here and see the
multiple dominance hierarchies that are at
work.
You can in a way,
because the chairs are set up to face
this way and I'm facing that way.
That gives you some clues about the
social order here and you take the cues
instantly,
right?
You come down,
you sit in the chairs,
you organize yourselves according to
mutual expectation and that's part of your
procedural knowledge about how
to behave as a social creature.
Now that knowledge is really,
really deep.
And a lot of it's coded in your behavior
now and another people's behavior as
well.
And that's,
you know,
that's,
that's the expectations
you have of other people,
end of yourself.
And a lot of those are implicit,
right?
So when we're interacting,
there's,
there's a,
there's a very large number of
things that you just don't get to do.
And you know that too,
and you won't do them.
And that way we can act as
if we understand each other,
even though we don't,
because you're really complicated.
And I'm really complicated and there's
lots of situations where we might really
be in conflict,
but because we share a map of the culture,
the cultural expectations,
it makes part of our,
it's built right into our perception.
You will act out that set of expectations.
And so will I,
and if neither of us can do that,
even if one of us can't,
we're going to stay.
We're either going to immediately devolve
into conflict or we're going to avoid
each other like the plague.
And that's exactly the right thing to do.